Você passa álcool no assento, forra com
papel higiênico, faz agachamento, mas
será que você tá se protegendo do perigo
errado esse tempo todo? Pois é, a
ciência acabou de revelar algo
surpreendente sobre banheiros públicos.
A chance de pegar uma DST do sexualmente
transmissível sentando no vaso, é
praticamente zero, seja gonorreia,
clamídia, HIV. Esses vírus de bactérias
morrem rapidinho fora do corpo. Até o
HPV, que é mais resistente, precisaria
de uma ferida aberta para entrar. O
estudo mostrou que os banheiros públicos
são limpos várias vezes ao dia, enquanto
o seu banheiro de casa só uma vez por
semana. Agora, o perigo real, que
ninguém fala, quando você dá descarga,
até 60% das partículas sobem em forma de
aerosol, o famoso espirro da privada. E
pior, suas mãos tocam na maçaneta, na
torneira, na descarga. E aí você coça o
olho, toca a boca e é assim que
neurovírus, esquiricha, cola e outras
bactérias te pegam. O chão do banheiro
tem muito mais germe que o assento.
Então, próxima vez no banheiro, público
dá descarga e sai correndo, lava bem as
mãos por 20 segundos e nunca jamais leva
o celular pro banheiro.